if you ask a mathematician what's the
strangest paradox in mathematics
there's nearly universal agreement it's
the banic tarsky paradox that i've
mentioned
many times creating two balls from one
taking one ball splitting it into a
finite number of pieces
and rearranging those to get two balls
of the same
size interestingly only a minority of
mathematicians have ever seen the proof
of this theorem
rarely discussed also are the
implications the corollaries of this
theorem
including you can take a pea-sized ball
split it up into finite number
a very large number of pieces and
reassemble them
move them rotate them and get a ball the
size of the sun
it's an astonishing result it's a fairly
complicated proof
there are several mathematics papers
that explain the proof to other
mathematicians
but there are very few attempts to
explain this to a general audience
that's what we're going to try to do in
this lecture
today it's just one paradox it's the
baniktarsky paradox
and it's complicated enough that i want
to give you a roadmap
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to look at a groups of words
that have two different letters
a and b and then we're going to split
those words into three types of words
and we'll see already that there's some
weirdness going on
finally we're going to use those words
to rotate the ball
and then once we've done that we're
going to define a set s
the definition of that set is going to
require the axiom of choice
we're going to split the ball into three
sets applying
these words that we've used we'll split
the ball into six sets and finally
we'll be able to make two balls from one
ball
now i'm going to brush over a few of the
details that require really advanced
mathematics i'll tell you when i'm doing
that
but the key ideas are all here and i'm
following
a paper of carl stromberg's it's a very
readable paper from 1979.
so let's jump in and talk about words
imagine all possible words i don't mean
actual words but
just using the letters a and b
finitely many copies of a and b and
like arabic i'm going to read these from
the right to the left
and so a word might be just a or just b
or just
b a or a b it might be long a b b b a a
a b b
a a now if you want to figure this out
how many of them are there
you can do a quick cardinality check
there's countably many
why because if you take any fixed length
say
length n there's just finitely many it's
two to the n
you could think about putting those two
to the n words on a bus
n but then you can line up all the buses
and you'd get all the words in order so
it would be countable
now eventually it's not just going to be
the letters a and b a
is going to be a 120 degree rotation
around one axis
and if you do that if you do that three
times you just get a 360 degree rotation
and that's the same as doing nothing
in other words aaa is going to be the
same as doing nothing at all
b on the other hand is going to be a 180
degree rotation
around a different axis and if it's a
180 degree rotation
if you do it twice bb that's going to be
a 360 rotation and that's the same as
doing nothing
and so because of that because of how
we're going to use the a and the b
we're going to remove any time we have
three a's in a row or two b's in a row
we're going to remove them
if you think of this it's sort of like
multiplication and then aaa
is the same as multiplying by one and b
b b i'm sorry b
b is also the same as multiplying by one
so if we take this word
a b b b a a a b b a a
we see three a's in a row and we can
just get rid of them
and then we see four b's in a row and we
can get rid of those
and what we end up with is a b a a
it's a little bit like simplifying a
fraction you know when you simplify a
fraction you think
i might as well simplify it it looks
better in the gate this case it's the
same thing we might as well take out as
many copies of three a's in a row
and two b's in a row as we can
can also write a squared when we have a
a and that makes things a little bit
simpler
and once you do that you see that every
word alternates
b's with either a or b or a squared
so you might have b a b a squared b
a b a b a squared something like that
we're going to put all of these words
into a set and we're going to call it g
and it has a sort of a multiplication
we'll just use star for that we combine
words just by appending one to the other
we call this concatenation but you have
to remember we're reading right to left
mathematicians sometimes do this and
you've probably done this with composite
functions if you take
f of g of x you write it as f
of g meaning you do g first the thing on
the right and then
f and so if we were to take a b a
squared and concatenate with a squared b
a we would just push those together and
in this case we can simplify we have a
to the fourth in the middle there
and we simplify and we get a b a b a
i want you to notice here that every
word has sort of an
anti-word the word aba has the anti word
a
squared b a squared they annihilate each
other in the following sense if you
concatenate them
you get an a cubed in the middle and a
cubed is a
a that's gone and then you get a b
squared in the middle
and that's gone and then finally you get
a cubed and that's gone
and so everything disappears we'll call
that one we'll call the the unit
if you think about rotations each word
is going to be a complicated sequence of
rotations
and the anti-word is the process for
undoing that sequence of rotations
the technological language of
mathematics this is a group
like the integers with addition except
we have this particular set of words
with concatenation
and these anti-words are the inverses
this particular group
is called a free group on two elements
modulo a
cubed and b squared
we always like to visualize things if we
can so let's see if we can visualize
this
particular group we can think of each
word as a node in a graph
every node gets some word and
we can start off with easy ones one the
absence of either letter
a and a squared and if you think about
it they should form a triangle because
they sort of go around
every time you go around this triangle
you pend an a one
if you append an a you get a you append
another a you get a
squared and it's a triangle because if
you append another a you get back to one
because a
cubed disappears how about the b's how
do we visualize those
well let's use curved lines to represent
appending a b
because if you have b by itself that's
just one
with b appended and then if you append b
again if you operate with b
you get b squared and that's back to one
you see multiplying by b
twice gets you back to where you just
were
and so the a's come in triangles a a one
a
a squared and then a cubed is one again
and the b's come in pairs
if you draw them with curved lines you
can think about them as little footballs
one b and then b squared is back to one
this lets you build out this diagram you
can have
a and b and you can have a b squared
so you get a football that's attached to
a
you have a squared b but then a squared
b squared that's just the same thing as
a squared so you're back to that
vertex on the triangle it's a football
attached to a squared
this graph which mathematicians call a
cayley diagram it keeps moving outward
triangles are attached to footballs and
footballs are attached to triangles
out as far as you can imagine
let's check just to make sure we
understand this let's see if we can find
the word a squared b a b
let's see a squared you have to go two
thirds around the first triangle to get
to a
squared and then you want b so you go
halfway around the football to get to a
squared b
and next is a that's 1 3 around the next
triangle to get to a squared b
a and then halfway around the next
football to get to a squared b
a b and there we are
that's where the word is notice
that there are alternative spellings of
the same word
we could insert a cubed or b squared
into this word
and you would end up in the same place
and you could think about following your
path around this any time you do an a
cubed you're just going around a
triangle and you end up around the same
place
anytime you have b squared you go once
around a football
the diagram exactly represents the words
and this relation that we have that a
cubed and b
squared are gone
all right next we're going to color
these vertices we're going to color the
words
in a very particular way so let's start
in the middle this main triangle
one let's call let's color that navy a
let's color that orange and a squared
let's color that purple
that way we get n o and p navy orange
and purple
now the next layer let's color the b
orange
and ba let's color that navy and a
squared b
let's color that navy as well
and let's make a pattern here let's make
a rule for this the triangles let's
always color them counterclockwise
navy orange purple nop and if we have
footballs it's a little bit more
complicated as we color
our way out from the middle if the inner
dot is navy
then let's color the next one out orange
and if the inner dot is orange or purple
let's color the outside one navy
in other words in every football one of
the two ends of the football is navy
and the other end is either orange or
purple
the next layer of triangles it's the
same as before nop
navy orange purple clockwork
counterclockwise this is a clear
algorithm
we just keep coloring out toward
infinity and in doing this every node
gets colored just one color
so if you look closely there's already
something weird about this and this is
sort of a preview of the weirdness to
come
every node is on a triangle and every
triangle is navy orange purple in order
and that means in some sense one-third
of the vertices whatever that means
because it's an infinite number but
one-third of those
are each of those colors one-third navy
one-third orange one-third purple
but let's look at the footballs you see
every node is also on a football
and one of the two ends is navy and the
other end is either orange or purple
that means in some sense half of the
nodes are navy
and the other half are either orange or
purple
see how this works exactly you see if
you take any word in navy and parrot and
append an
a to it on the left you go one leg
around a triangle the color of the new
word is always orange
you take any word that's in orange you
append an a the next word is always
purple
you do another a and you always get navy
every triangle is nop
in counterclockwise order so the sets of
navy dots orange dots and purple dots
they're the same size
in fact you can get from one to the
other in a one-to-one
correspondence by applying a on the left
and then here's the weirdness if you
take any orange or purple and apply b
you definitely get navy if you take any
navy and apply b you get orange or
purple it's equivalent to saying every
football shape
has one end that's navy and the other
that's either orange or purple
so applying a gives a one-to-one
correspondence among
all three applying a goes you from the
navy to the orange to the purple and
back again
but applying b gives a one-to-one
correspondence between the navy points
and the union of the orange and the
purple
we can visualize this and you can think
of each color as sort of its own set its
own circle
we're going to need colors later and so
i really want to stop talking about
the colors and just stick with n o and p
so
if you apply a to every word in a set
you just go from
n to o and if you apply a again you get
p
and if you apply a again you get back to
n
if you have one of these sets you can
get to any other just by applying
a the right number of times what happens
if you apply
b if you apply b to n you get both o
and p some navy words when you apply b
become orange and some of them when you
apply b you get purple
but if you apply b to o and p together
you get all of
n you get no overlap when you do that
and essentially that splits and the navy
points we'll call it and stick to the
letters
into two parts one part is the part
that's mapped to n from p when you
append
b to the we'll call that part p b
appending b to a word that is p
the second part is the part that's
mapped to n from o
when you append b to it and we'll call
that ob
now the weirdness is already here if you
have
pb and you add b on the left side you
get b
squared p and that's p
but but p if you append a to it
you get p a you get all of n
in other words p b it seems like half of
n
but when you take p b and you append b
and then
a well the b squareds are gone you just
get p
a and that's all of n applying
b a to half of n you get all of n
and weirdly you can do it with the other
half too if you have ob
and you apply b you get ob squared
that's o
and now you apply a squared you get o a
squared
and o a squared you take o around that's
p a and that's just n
so there's actually two reasons this
isn't quite that weird
i mean we saw when we were talking about
infinity that like the natural numbers
were countable
the even natural numbers were countable
and the odds were also countable
in other words the naturals you can
split into two pieces the evens and the
odds
and both halves of those can match up
one to one with the naturals
and there's another reason we should
expect this sort of weirdness by now
another word lecture 23.
you see this cayley diagram it's fractal
it's self-similar
if you look at it you can take one third
of this diagram if you blow it up
it now looks like a little bit more than
two-thirds of the original diagram
we know that self-similar objects have
strange properties small parts are
equivalent to large parts
subsets don't behave like they do for
finite sets
think back to the set paradox as
infinity
but why is it that this nop splitting
still is really paradoxical
to understand why it's still weird
remember the goal
in baniktarsky a and b are going to be
rotations
splitting up a set of words that are in
n
that's going to turn into splitting up a
set
take half rotate it twice to get the
full set
take the other half rotate it twice also
to get the full set
that's strange when we're talking about
natural numbers
when we're talking about stretching and
deforming the evens and the odds we sort
of have to push the evens together to
get
a one-to-one correspondence with the
naturals
when we think of rotations we're
thinking of just rigid motions
we think that's a lot more restrictive
baniktarsky is saying that those
rotations
are stranger than we think
so let's preview a key step in
baniktarsky
we're going to work for now on the group
of words g but eventually we're going to
do the same exact thing on the sphere
so remember n the set we we called navy
but now we're going with
n that's split that's split by where o
and p
map to when we apply b so if we apply
a to both halves of n well that
goes over and it splits o into two
pieces which we should call
pba and oba and if we apply a
again that splits p into two pieces
which are
pba squared and oba squared
and now we have that the group g is
split into six
pieces so let's take a look at these six
pieces
and see if we can do with them what we
want to do with bonik aktarsky
can we take those six pieces that make
up g and somehow
create two full copies of g let's see
how that works
take ob and pb and apply b
what do you get when you do those you
get o and p
now take o b a squared and p
be a squared apply a and what do you get
when you do that
you get ob and pb and now apply
b and you get o and p again
look what we've done we've taken four
pieces and each one of them seemed like
one sixth of g
and we've turned each piece turning
because we're applying
a and b which are rotations we've turned
each piece
and each piece has become one third of g
you see we almost have two full copies
of g already
and we've only used four of the six
pieces we're only missing
a copy of n in both copies
so that's the last part to create two
copies of n from the two remaining parts
of
o the bottom half of o we'll call it oba
let's take oba if we apply a squared
we get ob now if we apply b
we just we get o and not just half of it
the whole thing
o now we apply a squared and we get
n can you see how that last piece the
last piece is
pba can you see how you could transform
it to get n
it's good practice it's a favorite line
of math teachers everywhere
we'll leave this one as an exercise it's
not that different from the others
for now let's go to the quick conundrum
which is mathematical magic
creating two balls from one
which is what the baniktarsky paradox is
all about
the quick conundrum is a little magical
as well
boniktarsky is saying that we can create
two balls from one
you know turns out both mathematicians
and magicians do that magicians do this
with sleight of hand you have one ball
and all of a sudden it's two or one dove
and all of a sudden it's two
mathematicians are actually proving that
it can be done although the pieces it
turns out aren't measurable
here's a similar problem tying a knot in
a rope the
question here is can you grab the ends
of the rope and then
tie it into a knot somehow without
letting go
and if you try this at home you'll
quickly find that it you think it's just
not possible
but i have two solutions for you one's
mathematical and one's magical let's
let's try the magical one so i'm
grabbing the rope and i'll just sort of
do something like this and i just say
there's a knot that's just gonna appear
in the middle
oh let me try that one more time so i i
wind it around or something like that
and oh look
there's the knot so that's the
magician's way
um mathematicians have a different way
of solving this puzzle and the way to do
that
is to tie the knot in your arms before
you pick up
the rope and then you untie your arms
and there's the knot right in the middle
magicians they can tie a knot they can
turn one object into two
mathematicians we can do both as well
[Music]
decomposing g the group of words with
a's and b's where a cubed is equal to b
squared is one that's the heart of
baniktarsky
that wasn't proved by baniktarsky it was
proved in 1914 by the german
mathematician
felix hausdorff he also did the next
step
he applied this to when a and b are
rotations of the sphere where a is a
rotation
around the north pole of 120 degrees one
third of the way around so that a cubed
is
the identity and b is a rotation around
some other axis of 180 degrees
so you do a three times you get back to
where you start you do b2
times you get back to where you start
it's important to choose the axis for
the b
rotation we want to make sure the angle
between the north pole and the b
axis doesn't divide 360 degrees in any
rational number
if we're thinking in radians it's not a
rational fraction of pi
we do that to make sure that no
simplified word gets back to one
all right so now every word we have
say a b a squared b a it's a sequence of
rotations
we need a fact about this see if you
have a sequence of rotations if you
rotate and then rotate and then rotate
it's equivalent to one single rotation
it's actually an easy fact if you know
some linear algebra a rotation is just a
three by three matrix with determinant
one
and so if you have a sequence of
rotations you're just multiplying those
matrices
and the result is another three by three
matrix with determinant one which is
itself
a single rotation
the rest of the proof of boniktarsky is
going to
follow very closely with the
construction of non-measurable sets
we're going to think of different sets
as colored and where the number of
different colors is going to be
uncountable
we're going to create a new set str s
for strange
we're going to have one point of each
color in that set and then we're going
to see how the rotations the words in g
act on s we're going to use the
splitting of g
to create subsets of the sphere and then
the paradox that we already saw with g
is going to become the paradox on the
sphere
once we have the paradox on the sphere
which is just the outer shell
we can extend those sets inward to get a
paradox on the entire sphere
and that's baniktarsky
so let's remember that the set g is
countable each word is finite
and the points on the sphere are
uncountable so given
x a point on the sphere we can look at
x and then we apply g all of these
different words for instance you could
take
x and apply a b a squared b a
when you do that with all of g you get a
set of points
you get what we call the orbit and it's
a countable orbit because
g itself is a countable group if we
start with
a different point z there's two
possibilities
you see either the orbit is exactly the
same as it was for
x or there's no points in common those
two
those two orbits are completely
disjoined
and we can call these things equivalence
classes and each one because they're
disjoint we could color each one a
different color
remember this isn't the navy orange
purple that we were doing before those
are just letters now now we can color
these
red and yellow and the problem is that
there's uncountably many of these
equivalence classes and we have to use
uncountably many colors which we did
last time when we were looking at an
unmeasurable set
it's really point important here that
every point on the sphere is some color
every point is in some one of these
orbits and if we have two points that
are of the same color say
x and y then there is some word in g
when when we take x and we rotate by
that word we get y
if you have two points that are of
different colors say x and z
then there is no word in g that we'll
take x and apply that word and get to z
and now that we have an uncountable
number of different sets
different colors you know what we're
going to use we're going to pull out the
axiom of choice
so let's let s for strange let's let s
be the set with
exactly one point of each color we had
uncountably many colors
that means that s is going to be a set
with uncountably many points
now this is incredibly hard to picture
this is an
unmeasurable set already which makes it
really hard to visualize but you can
still follow the argument
if you pick a point that's not in s
let's call it z
then z has some color and there's
exactly one point in s
that has the same color we pick only one
point of each color
let's call that point w so w and z have
the same color
but if they have the same color that
means there exists a word in g that
rotates w to get
z if we think of only simplified words
then that choice is unique
and that means that every point on the
sphere we can get to it in just one way
by rotating some point in s by some
simplified word in g
if we rotate the entire set s by all of
the words in g
we get the entire sphere if we take s
and apply
all of g we get the entire sphere
now we look at hausdorff's splitting of
g we split g
into these sets n o and p g is n
union o union p and
now we think about what happens when we
apply those words to our set s
if g applied to s is the entire sphere
we can think of that in three parts
just n applied to s just the words of g
that were in n applied to s
union the words in o applied to s union
the words in
p that are applied to s you see
the sets on the sphere that are
s n s o and s p
those have the same strange property as
the sets of
words n o and p which were in g
now just like before the rotation a
cycles among these three sets except now
it's not cycling among
words in g it's cycling among sets which
are on the sphere
if we have the set s n and we apply a we
get the set
s o if we apply a again we get sp
if we apply a again we get s n
and so these three subsets of the sphere
they some sort of form a triangle in
some sense
the rotation b it cycles between s and
and the union of s o and s p
you have s n you apply b you get the
union of s o and s p
you apply b again and you're back to s n
and the same splitting as before works
it's easily easier to visualize it as
before
but really these are pieces on the
sphere which are
incredibly complicated and all over and
not measurable
this splits the sphere into six pieces
and just like before we can take three
of them and reassemble them to make
an entire sphere take the other three
and reassemble them
to make the entire sphere again see
for the group g it was six pieces it was
things like
pb and ob and pba we have rearranged
those six by applying a and b in the
correct way
to get two entire copies of g
now we're doing that on the sphere now
the six pieces are things like
spb and sob and spba
we rearrange those by applying a and b
which are just rotations of the sphere
we rearrange those six pieces to get
two entire copies of the sphere
and then we're essentially done
g is split into six pieces that's the
group that's split into six pieces and
we can
rearrange those to get two copies of g
we use g to split the sphere the key
fact here is that when we apply
any word in g to s it never overlaps
with
s when we apply all of g to s we get the
entire
sphere the splitting that we have of g
into six
pieces allows us to get a splitting of
the entire sphere into six pieces when
we apply those pieces to the set s
when we apply just parts of g to s we
get pieces that behave
just as strangely as they did when we
were thinking of them as just
words in g
the hard part the really paradoxical
part is done
to get from the sphere the shell to the
ball
we have to extend these points inward
towards zero
and then we can create two balls
out of one
there's two additional complications
that i at least want to mention
and they require really technical fixes
one is that every rotation fixes two
points the ends of the rotation the
poles if you will
and those points are a problem but
luckily
g is countable it's a countable set and
each
word in g fixes two of these points and
so it's just a countable number of
problems
where we have this
the second problem is the center of the
sphere we extended things in from the
shell toward the center
but we didn't say what to do at the very
center of the sphere the center is not
in any set
now these problems are countable well
one of those is
countable where you rotate the fixed
points and the other is just a single
point but together they make up a
countable set
and it was banach and tarsky who found a
complicated and
ingenious fix for this fairly
problematic part of this if you can't
solve that problem you can't finish off
the
proof it's tricky it's extremely
technical and it's sort of brilliant
but we want to make sure we understand
something about all these pieces that
we've split the sphere into
you see s the set we made the strange
set with one point of each color
it is necessarily unmeasurable it's the
same argument as before
suppose s were measurable well every
rotation of s
would have the same measure if we take i
know b
a squared b a and apply it to s we get
some rotation of it it should have the
same measure
the measure of the entire sphere is 4 pi
it has a surface area
and that's a countable union of sets all
of which have the same measure
s can't have measure zero because if you
added up a countable number of times you
would get zero
ass can't have a positive measure either
if you added up that up uncountable
number of times you would get infinity
this thing that baniktarsky does you
divide the sphere up into six pieces and
reassemble them into two spheres
it's clearly not possible with a knife
these pieces are not nice in any way
they're unmeasurable
it's not even not possible to accurately
visualize this the pieces are just
too complicated for that
but the full bonutarsky paradox
is even stranger than just one ball see
if you can do this trick with one ball
you could do it again you could
do it with any set made of balls of any
size you can take a p
split it up into a finite number of
pieces and
make 500 p's or if you want to do that
into more pieces
you could reassemble them into a ball
the size of the sun
any bounded set with non-empty interior
you can cut into
pieces reassemble and make any other
such set
interestingly there's no such paradox in
one dimension in the number line
or in the plane but really
banachtarski it's the ultimate
mathematical mind bender
sets infinity fractals dimension it's
all rolled into this one big paradox
baniktarsky
space set size none of these work like
we think
and this broadens our understanding our
view of the world
next time it's our last lecture and
we're going to introduce a few new
paradoxes
mostly with the goal of tying all these
things together
but we're also going to return to the
question that we posed back in the very
first lecture
why is it that we think about paradoxes
in counter-intuitive puzzles
that is in some sense the paradox of
paradoxes
till next time
[Music]
you